joining us on the line is stephen
crowder host of louder with crowder
he was once demonetized by youtube for
not violating their policies now
a year later he has been remonetized by
youtube the question is do they even
know that happened steven
welcome to the show thank you for having
me i appreciate it yes i was demonetized
for not violating policy uh
you are the first journalist to get it
correctly yeah it is amazing basically
there was a guy named carlos mazza he
was mad that you were making jokes about
him
and so youtube basically said you didn't
violate their policies
but they had demonetized you because
carlos mazza is a whiny baby
and uh and that was the going i think
that was actually the language they used
and that is and for a year you were
unable to make money off of your videos
automatically so now
my real question is like do they even
know that they remonetized you or did it
sort of like automatically expire
no no no so this was a while and i've
been told by my legal accounts that i
can't discuss this we have been having
conversations for
a year and a half with youtube uh going
back and forth and we had removed
uh two dozen older videos we removed the
shirt from the merch shop and it just
kind of ended up being these calls where
it was
brow beating and can you change this to
the
bordering on suggestions that would be
inappropriate um but then we did know
that we had sort of met the criteria for
whatever reason people who watch the
show know their content hasn't gotten
less offensive uh they let us know that
we would be remonetized
and we said okay and we didn't go public
with it until it was
happening and for some reason the verge
owned by vox by the way
got the scoop before anyone could have
possibly known only youtube and us
no one else had access to the account no
one could know when the re-monetization
was going to take place
and they managed to write a full-length
story of which they did not ask me for
comment
before we announced anything publicly
the day after so that's the question
that i would like answered so that means
that 25 seconds from now there will be a
wave of outrage
and then youtube presumably will be
recommended to demonetize you again so
you will have approximately
two days of monetization so
congratulations on the uh
on the on the raise on the very small i
plan on going to pinks and getting
myself a smorgasbord
yeah it really i listen here's the deal
the monetization it's nice
uh because it wipes off the only win on
the scoreboard that vox nbc had that's
really all it is
but my main priority has always been and
if ever youtube has reached for comment
i hope that they would be
straightforward in in
discussing this i said if you it's your
right to not monetize this i understand
that
i have the right to be on your platform
if it's an open platform with the legal
protections that are afforded to you
i do not i am not entitled to make money
but my argument my fight was always i
want to make sure that our content is
still on this platform not being
throttled
not being treated unfairly to uh
comparable leftist content that was in
the monetization was a surprise to me
and it was a certainly a surprise to me
to see the verge
and uh and vox get the scoop on it
before we announce how does that happen
i don't know ben just like magic just
like magic okay stephen
well while i have you on the line i want
to ask you about some of the stuff
that's been going on in our politics
it's been a while
since we've chatted i mean you have a
full beard so it's been at least four
days since we chatted
because when i last saw you there was no
beard you're just enough of a man that
in four days you've been able to grow a
full
paul bunyan beer i did at my 23andme and
somewhere there's a little lebanese so
so let's talk about the the presidential
race president trump obviously down
pretty heavily in the polls right now
joe biden
has selected a vp candidate in kamala
harris who so wildly enthused people
that she dropped out before a single
primary but now apparently
everybody is so enthused by her being
picked as a vp i've not seen this level
of enthusiasm since the last nickelback
concert frankly
and i'm wondering about your your
thoughts on kamala harris
the vastly exciting new vice
presidential candidate who five minutes
ago is calling joe biden a racist to
sexually harassed women
okay well that was going to be my what i
was going to because i think everyone is
pointing out right the the sort of
indiscretions everyone's pointing out
the inconsistencies
with her uh prosecuting nonviolent drug
offenders with her extending sentences
right with her
really being uh an anti-sort of social
justice prosecutor and now claiming that
mantle
uh of course also claiming that she
listened to tupac uh before it actually
was a thing so
yes my question is this was there ever a
conversation
because effectively kamala harris
publicly decried
uh joe biden as really you could
summarize it as like a rapey jim crow
basically he said i believe you're
sexual accusers and you supported
segregation
in one form or another or stood on a
platform of people who did so that's
really
was there a conversation between her and
biden when he announced
her going like okay but listen joe you
did it right i mean
you want to know the answer to that i
had brian callan on the show yesterday
who had these accusations
and the first thing i said was brian did
you do it are you a rapist
and he answered no i could not have a
relationship with someone especially if
i had been someone publicly accusing
them of sexual assault
and then running a ticket with them
without hashing it out so that's what i
wonder
i don't think they have because i think
that this is entirely about political
expediency
they are not genuine and i will say this
i know the polls have uh donald trump
behind but here's something that
interests me and you're more of a
political warning than i am
but the recent poll that came up from
master mission 36 of african americans
support uh donald trump which is a
record high outside of george bush
right after 9 11 right if you just get
half of that
to vote for donald trump in states like
ohio and michigan you're talking about
wayne county you take areas like
columbus cincinnati toledo
that would make a huge difference in the
rust belt
and kamala harris is unbe surprisingly
unpopular for a biracial vice
presidential candidate
uh it's almost like joe biden doesn't
want to win this election but
i don't know i mean what i've been
amazed by is is the fact that
he's been so obvious and transparent in
the fact that he is not going to survive
his first term i mean
he's almost he's almost saying it
straight out i mean he says he's a
transitional figure
and yet the media are treating him as
though he is
a robust character i mean brian stelter
this week on reliable sources the most
reliable of all sources
he did a whole montage of various
conservatives talking about joe biden's
health
and then he played a video of joe biden
riding a bicycle and he said
look joe biden's riding a bicycle how
dare you question the vigorous nature of
joe biden's mind
and i was like my four-year-old son
rides a bicycle there's a homeless guy
who rides a bicycle down my street
before the front wheel falls off he
takes a crowbar out of the back of the
bike
and then just beats living crap out of
his bike i don't feel like either of
those people is qualified to be
president
mentally so i'm just wondering exactly
how the media have shifted the narrative
to joe biden is vigorous and robust
again when it's pretty obvious that
harris will be the president if he is
elected
bob i think you're being unfair to
stealth let me explain why you know how
this works in this industry where you
plan a segment and maybe things don't
fully come together
would have been a great segment had
stelter as he thought he would gotten
the rights to the queen catalog
but then unfortunately it just ended up
being this clip with no music and it's
just awkward at that point so seltzer
did more harm than good
uh yeah i think the beauty of this
though ben is that it really
is and i don't think anyone other than
donald trump could have done this
because he is so bombastic because
he he is so uh i guess he could
say uh prickly for these folks that now
they actually go out and are carrying
the water for joe biden and it is so
clear when you juxtapose what someone
like stelter says with
how joe biden speaks or acts that this
is someone who's really trying to drag
them past the finish line you know when
he had a barack obama i think a lot of
people didn't really see the media bias
at play
because they didn't have to drag barack
obama across the finish line listen this
is a guy who was articulate this is a
guy who could speak well this is a guy
who could inspire people
but then with hillary clinton we kind of
saw it because she's immensely unlikable
and now with joe biden they're going why
should you have to take a cognitive test
the fact that they're saying there
shouldn't be any debates it's so clear
for the american public when you have
these weak
candidates that it's it's surprising to
me it is remarkable that
the left has almost all of hollywood
almost all the mainstream media when i
say that abcmccbs
msnbc cnn they have almost all of the
music industry almost all public sector
workers
all of education and they still lose
elections
how it is it is an incredible
incredible thing all right so stephen if
you had to give advice to president
trump at this point
what would your debate advice for him be
with joe biden i i basically suggested
that he should just call
biden a not a live person to his face on
the stage i think he should just pretend
that joe biden doesn't exist anything
biden says he should say listen
i appreciate your perspective joe if you
can even remember it from like 30
seconds ago but
you are not going to be the president
your vp is and so now let's talk about
the person who's actually going to be
president kamala harris because
the the big problem he's had so far is
being able to categorize biden in any
way biden
as we've talked about before he's a dead
horse it's hard to beat a dead horse
but at this point he's made clear that
the person he's selected to replace him
if god forbid something happens to him
is going to be a radical like kamala
harris what would you advise trump to do
well it is hard to beat a dead horse but
i'm a fan of glue so i do think he
should go out there
uh and show up first donald trump shows
up that's half the battle and we say
that
sort of colloquialism showing up is half
the battle in this case showing up is
really half the win
uh because it's donald trump and joe
biden and joe biden may not show up
mentally
outside of that um yeah i think you're
right that he should call into question
his mental faculties what i would do if
i were donald trump
is call backs what do i mean i would
give out i would
state some things with great specificity
early on in the debate
and call it back and then toss the onus
to
joe biden well what we talked about
earlier because i guarantee you joe
biden won't remember
it that and that's just me that's what i
would do i've had to do some head games
before when we've done debates or even
before when i used to compete in in uh
combat sports it is there is an art of
warfare and getting in someone's head
and if i were donald trump
i would front load it with a lot of rat
tat tat facts information
and try and call joe biden's attention
back to them later on in the debates
he won't know where he is and i think if
anything it'll it'll be sad
um that sounds fantastic actually i just
in the first
30 seconds of the debate he should just
look at joe biden and say people
woman man television bird
and then like 45 minutes come back see
joe do you remember what those words
were
just like a real life game of duel and
back where it's like three
n you know you have to remember two
spaces back exactly actual
the actual mental competency test on
stage i think that'd be kind of
fantastic well steven crowder
congratulations on your remonetization
and condolences in advance your
demonetization one week from now
stephen crowder of louder with crowd
really appreciate it dude thank you sir
appreciate it brother
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content